سيدي وزير الخارجية ، إن اجتماعًا كهذا
هو الأول من نوعه منذ سنوات عديدة ،
لذا فإن اللاعبين الإقليميين والدوليين
والمشاركين في كل من السياسة
والأمن يصفون فقط أهمية
قمة أكبر هذه ، إذا كنت
ستشكرك بيكي ، فقد كان الاجتماع
تتويجًا لجهود هائلة  الجهد الذي بذله
الملك في الغالب
لجمع الأطراف معًا
ضد المهمة المظلمة المتمثلة في
الانهيار الكامل لأي مشاركة ذات مغزى على
هذا النحو أه جمع الأطراف
تحت مظلة الولايات المتحدة
كان وجود الرؤساء المصريين والأردنيين
خطوة سياسية مهمة لمحاولة تحقيق بعض الأمور
المشتركة  الإحساس بالطاولة
والتحدث عن إجراءات حقيقية يمكن أن تهدئ من
تصعيد الموقف ويقول
هذا كله أه خطر
اندلاع المزيد من العنف وفقدان الأمل
جيدًا بينما أفادت التقارير أن كلا الجانبين الإسرائيلي وقصر
أم عبروا عن استعدادهم
لمنع المزيد  لقد شهدنا سلسلة
من الهجمات في أعقاب ذلك بين
المستوطنين الإسرائيليين والفلسطينيين والتي
دفعت جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي إلى إرسال
تعزيزات إضافية إلى الضفة الغربية بالنظر إلى
هذه الخلفية أن ما يجري على
الأرض عندما تحصل هذه الأطراف
على طاولة واحدة يفعل  ترى
القمة نجاحا
فالقمة التي كانت بيكي مهمة في
بدء نقاش سياسي جاد
شهد لقاء الأمس
مفاوضات صريحة جدا وقاسية جدا أه
حول ما يجب القيام به لمنع
المزيد من العنف مرة أخرى كانت الأولى
من نوعها  خلال السنوات الماضية ، تمخضت عن اتفاق
يلتزم فيه الطرفان بالعمل معًا لوقف التصعيد لإنهاء
التدابير الأحادية
والالتزام بالاتفاقية الموقعة سابقًا ،
وذلك باعتباره نتاجًا سياسيًا
كخطوة سياسية كانت مهمة للغاية
ولكن الوضع على
الأرض هو الذي  سوف تحتاج إلى معالجة
الآن تنفيذ ما تم الاتفاق عليه
ووقف
الإجراءات الأحادية وغير الاستفزازية التي
تستمر في الدفع نحو المزيد من العنف
وكما ذكرت أن الاجتماع في العقبة
انعقد ضد
الحادثة المروعة على الغرب أمس والتي
تكشفت أثناء اجتماعنا.  وهذا
سبب آخر لأهمية تلك اللقاءات
لأنه ما
لم يتكلم الطرفان ما لم نحاول التوصل إلى
اتفاق أه نحن ننظر إلى
وضع أسوأ للمضي قدمًا في أحد
الالتزامات
بمناقشة أي
[موسيقى] جديدة لمدة
أربعة أشهر.
أم فيما يتعلق بالتزام مماثل تم
التعهد به الأسبوع الماضي بعد أن
عبر مجلس الأمن الدولي عن مخاوف عميقة لذلك
سيكون هناك من يقول ما هو جديد حقًا
هنا أه
بالتأكيد أه من الواضح أن
الحكومة الإسرائيلية اتخذت أه سابقًا قرارًا
ببناء المزيد من المستوطنات شيء
بالطبع وهو  ندين كرائد
لن يؤدي إلا إلى تقويض أه
آفاق السلام وتقويض
حل الدولتين أه لكن بالأمس كانت
المرة الأولى التي اجتمع فيها الطرفان حيث
بدأ التفاوض
والتزم الإسرائيليون بعدم مناقشة
أي تسويات جديدة وعدم  لترخيص
أي بؤر استيطانية جديدة غير شرعية أه لا
أعتقد أنها ستعكس القرار
الذي تم اتخاذه من قبل والذي نرغب فيه
وسنواصل العمل به
ولكن في النهاية ما حصلنا عليه
بالأمس هو اتفاق للعمل على
الإسكاليد للعمل  لوقف
الإجراءات الأحادية ولكل الطرفين
مصلحة في ذلك لأن أه
سيدفع
ثمنًا باهظًا من العنف الذي
نراه يتفجر خصوصًا مع
اقتراب شهر رمضان بأكمله
والذي يتزامن أيضًا مع
عيد الفصح نعم لأنه  ببساطة هناك الكثير
لنخسره هنا ، فهناك الكثير على المحك ،
وإذا تم تكريم الالتزام في العقبة
بالأمس ، فقد نرى
بعض التقدم نحو ذلك ، هل
يمكنك فقط
التأكيد لنا على المخاطر التي
نتعامل معها إذا كان الهدف  استعادة
السلام من خلال هذه القمة
بالطبع لم تتحقق
ما مدى قلقك ما هي المخاطر التي
تكون المخاطر عالية جدًا
وعلينا فقط أن ننظر إلى أحداث
العام الماضي وقبله لنرى أننا في طريقنا إلى
الانخفاض.  طريق خطير جدا أه
عدد القتلى الفلسطينيين في
العام الماضي لم يتم رؤيته
في أكثر من 10 15 سنة أه الشعب
يفقد الأمل اليأس يبتلع
الوضع برمته أه لذلك نحن نشهد
كمية هائلة من العنف تتفجر
نحن نشهد عنف المستوطنين ونرى
الراديكاليين أه يواصلون التحريض
ضد السلام ويستمرون في محاولة
دفعنا نحو الهاوية
لذلك الخطر حقيقي بيكي وإذا
لم نتمكن من  أه السيطرة على الوضع
ووقف المزيد من العنف ، يمكن أن
ننظر إلى اندلاع
دائرة جديدة من العنف قد تعني
الانهيار الكامل وقد تعني
مواجهات واسعة النطاق مقلقة للغاية
بينما لدي وزير الخارجية
أم يجب أن أضغط عليك.  زيارتك
لدمشق في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر التقيت بالرئيس
السوري باشا الأسد في
أعقاب ما كان
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب أه تركيا وسوريا
أكثر من 50 ألف قتيل الآن
في تلك المنطقة هو بشار الأسد
منبوذ.  على المسرح العالمي الآن
على هذه المنطقة أه الخليجية والشرق الأوسط الأوسع
كما قلتم أن الزيارة تمت
في أعقاب أه الزلزال المروع
الذي تسبب في مقتل عدد هائل
في كل من سوريا وتركيا
وبالتالي كانت الزيارة في البداية
تعبيرا عن التضامن مع
الشعب السوري وأيضا
الشعب التركي أه ولكن كانت فرصة
لمناقشة أه الوضع السياسي أه
موقفنا في الأردن دائما هو
أننا بحاجة للعمل نحو
حل سياسي للأزمة
الحقيقة  الاختيار هو أنه لم يكن هناك أي
جهد لحل الأزمة في
السنوات القليلة الماضية ، إنها سياسة الوضع الراهن
وهو شيء نعتقد أنه
ينتج المزيد من المعاناة والمزيد من
الخطر لهؤلاء السوريين والمنطقة على هذا النحو
في الأردن نحن زوجان
قبل سنوات أتينا بكتاب أبيض
هو الآن أه مبادرة أردنية
مبنية على
دور عربي رائد في انخراط سياسي
مع الحكومة السورية بهدف
التمويل التدريجي لحل
ينهي الأزمة وينهي الأزمة.
معالجة كل ما يترتب عليها من عواقب
إنسانية وسياسية وأمنية
كنا في نقاش مع شركاء
وأصدقاء في المنطقة وخارجها
حول هذه المبادرة
سنمضي قدماً فيها لأنها أه
مبادرة مرجعية تسعى إلى
نهج تدريجي على  أساس
الخطوة الرابعة وفي الأيام القادمة
ستشاهد Mojo DNA تتفاعل
مع الأصدقاء والشركاء
لتفعيل تلك المبادرة
البديل عن هذا هو أكثر من نفس الشيء
أكثر من نفس الشيء يعني المزيد من المعاناة أه
للشعب السوري عواقب أكثر خطورة
أه لنا جميعًا في
المنطقة وما بعدها